jean paul gaultier dont le sida la
fondation cartier pour l'art
contemporain aujourd'hui inventé la jupe
aura mais dernièrement le maquillage
pour hommes testés par vincent perez
josé garcia david beckham non il ya des
chaussées à la fois comme on l'a fred
tonifiant enfin cédé tonique et puis
aussi les chaudes par exemple pour les
lèvres pour se protéger l'élève mais en
même temps que leur est un peu si on
veut mais ça peut être aussi très nette
à la base et aussi pour j'ai pas les
sourcils ou comme comme le cool des
toits et une histoire et ses alentours
des yeux bon donc c'est des choses quand
même
on peut très bien les maîtres sans avoir
l'air maquillé forum politique mais je
crois c'est les neutres et alors on se
le passe avec un blaireau sait à quels
sont les gestes par exemple même pour
l'heure comme un stylo voilà si l'eau
parce que c'est un geste que un geste
d'airbus voilà quel peut être l'avenir
de la mode
on va vers une interview à la mode
est ce que vous pensez qu'un jour
pourrait être à la mode
les espadrilles montante ah oui tout à
fait les pantalons dans les chaussettes
totalement c'est pas beau quand même les
porte à leur guerre wilson tout va à
lambert wilson
même son nom mystérieux y mettrait le
pantin et chaussées les soutiens gorge
pour hommes
plus ça dure et non mais à laval ouais
c'est vrai et que tout ballon merlus
investi c'est comme ça les gens et les
gants il peut avoir des défenses il
dessine la morphologie masculine
peut-être musclé mais oui à partir du
moment où un rapport
c'est pas comme une prothèse quoi pour
pourrait donc lui string kangourou le
défendrai bien peut-être c'est déjà la
mode y en a certains qui l'est les
bretons coups de beats dans une peau de
bête
je veux dire faut avoir la [ __ ] plaisir
lors c'est comme les manceaux n'ont pas
de choix
c'était une pièce est jolie quand même
je me semblent possibles pour qu'aucun
nom il ya 26 ans fait comme ça il ya les
cadets ya des dépôts de poissons et tous
qui sont incroyables que les plans il ya
plein de choses qui sont faites donc la
peau de byd peut en effet être un
élément pourquoi pas peut-être qu'on
fera pas d merci c'est pourquoi qu'est
ce qu'il ya gauthier il ya aussi un
album et lycées par la fondation cartier
sur bayrou dubaï jean paul gaultier
ok
puis loïc